did did either one of you know Nick
Offerman not personally personally I
have known Nick Offerman for a long time
Megan malali is one of my dear friends
his wife we did the Revival of Greece
together back in
1994 I love it you know so I've I've
known them such a great couple and I
love him he's so talented he's a man of
many many many Talent y um he's an actor
a comedian an author and in the vein of
one of these things is not like the
other he's a woodworker too he literally
can build you like a new like it's crazy
last week when we were in rehearsals
getting ready to launch this new season
I was surprised when Nick popped up here
on the stage looking very dashing by the
way and apparently he just wanted to
make sure that the studio was in tiptop
shape for our new season here in New
York and he wanted to make sure it safe
so check this
out we just practice to walk on here
this is your first guest to come out we
just got a stand in coming in okay all
right everybody stand by wo here we go
all right everybody our first guest is
the only person ever woman or man to win
the three big awards for film TV and
Stage acting in both the US and the UK
please give it up for Dame Helen
[Music]
[Applause]
Mir you look so handsome Kelly you look
so beautiful what are you doing here I
was just in the neighborhood moving into
a new home is always difficult um and I
happen to be in the neighborhood Hood so
I thought I'd stop by and offer Kelly
any help that I possibly could do you
like what we've got going on I do I see
some Walnut I see some Oak yeah uh
sturdy yeah so we got to block some
games oh it's my Podium I know we still
got the lect turn of integrity and as I
was looking around the set I noticed you
know gratifyingly that they had brought
my lecturn of Integrity with them can
you tell me why does it say Jonas well
here's the thing Nick Jonas came and you
know we wanted to make him just feel
special yeah that's is he is he is he a
Furniture Builder no I don't think so oh
huh a musician named Nick Jonas had
added his name might as well have been
Judas there we go yeah i' I've got some
sandpaper right here we call that an
East Coast touchup I like it I mean you
know the Scuttle butt is that Joe Jonas
is very nice um but apparently Nick is a
real piece
of well I guess since we're here and and
uh what's this this I'm actually in town
promoting the paperback release of my
last book Thank you to mer to mer heart
Jonas the can
[Laughter]
Su I love it this is that'll show him I
know that's relatively well known know
that I know my way around a toolbox so
thought I'd sneak in and see if they
could use any help with my expertise in
scenery so stand by and just do a little
reading here okay perfect see how it's
going okay all right everybody so our
first guest is the only person ever
woman or man to win the three big awards
for film TV and Stage acting in both the
US and the
UK what's going on is it pretty good or
I've been known to be handy with a
hammer or a tape measure or roll a dry
wall tape is that just for rehearsal or
is this table GNA stay here you know I
think it might be
staying all right you might want to uh
you might want to replenish the finish
and it looks cool but you don't want you
don't want to spill gravy in it okay
well I don't want to spill gravy I just
want to eat it I don't want to spill any
of it there's one place to spill gravy
am I right in the in the gravy hole all
right every everybody we always like to
close out with something trending online
so this is what I'm
liking hey what's up Nick oh hey sorry
yeah don't worry about me we're just uh
we're just finishing up some final
tweaks do you know who did this tuck
pointing I you know what I don't even
know what you said if I'm being honest
all
right okay all right well you keep doing
you all right thank thank
you the risers at first glance are solid
but um the pine that they used for the
structure is a little bit naughty and
eventually that's going to need
reinforcements but for now it should be
fine the coffin locks that they're using
to lock in the
platforms uh seem to be like an aluminum
alloy yes they're a little bit cheaper
but come check with me in 3 years and
see if those things are still
operating the contion rods won't last
you more than 18 months hope I was able
to help out a little bit um I'm glad to
be a good neighbor whenever I can and
best of luck to Kelly with the new
season I'm sure it's going to be
terrific can't wait to come
back I got
it
one more time y'all give it up the Nick
offer I love you so much this book we
the deer and the antelope play is now
available on paperback and it will be on
permanent display on my set because I
love him all right so you can also see
Nick on his us Comedy Tour right now
he's hilarious go see him you'll feel
good about yourself go online for
tickets if you want to go see
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home